hey guys what's up this is andrew with
trendsenses.com
and i'm here to make a huge update on
gamestop
let's get into it
[Music]
and guys so let's start on the first
time frame as usual
let me quickly sum up what i was saying
in my previous video
so i made my last video uh here
around the 106th level and i was telling
you that
we got rejected by this
downward sloping trend line that was the
basis of a triangle that actually never
happened
because it was broken here you guys
maybe remember this if you watch my
previous video
so it was support it acted then as
resistance
let's zoom in quickly here let's see
what happened
it was here support broken then acted as
resistance
got rejected and then we went higher
and you can see guys so once again i
don't want to
make anything that is not clean i
connect this low and this low here
so this one is almost touched but it's
fine and here you can see
that it's actually acted almost here
as the support we had on
tuesday's session so it was just a small
thing i wanted to show
you because once you spot a support or
resistance then it lasts usually a
couple of days and it is useful for
their training
so whatever here if i take a step back
we are exactly in my scenario guys
so it looks very good to me we are doing
the third wave so i'm expecting
this third wave to go to the 195
level then get rejected you know
we basically now are trading above this
you know very important pivot point that
i'm talking about in every video i make
on gamestop
so here you can see we traded above on
the first time frame we confirmed
then we had a small you know breakout
that got supported
here as you can see by this upward
sloping trend line
uh that was the basis of my triangle and
we basically
are still trading above 173
which is for me the major level and on
the daily timeframe we just got the
confirmation guys
so it doesn't mean that you know we're
gonna
remain bullish it is just one more
indicator that is telling us that
my preferred scenario remains the
preferred scenario it's
just one more thing to add to the whole
analysis
so here let me go back on the first time
frame so this is very good
so we are heading to the 195
level and then i expected so as i said
to correct 173
one more time this would be my first
wave and then to make a fifth wave and
break
this resistance guys that is for me the
most important one let me put it in red
let me put it bigger
we need to break this guys all right i
connect this high and this high
once again guys i'm on the log scale i
had some of you asking me how
do you come up with those level by
connecting this high and this high guys
log scale all right
if i'm not on a log scale then it is
giving me
different signals that can be valid that
can be valid as well
you know you can do your charts like
this you just need to basically stay
consistent
and to see where you have the best
signals on the
charts like gamestop guys where
basically we go from 45
to 400 in a couple of days i don't like
to use
arithmetical scales i don't like it
because it is not reflecting the reality
the reality is happening in terms of
returns
it's not absolute values when gap stop
is at 300 it can go
higher or lower by 100 points much
easier than when it is
at two so this is what block scale is
showing you it is showing you that
the higher the price action is the more
it can move
on your charts so i come back here
so i expect yeah something like this
guys okay
so for me this didn't happen all right
it didn't happen yet and we need
this to happen so that we have nothing
else that is actually stopping the price
action to go higher
just technically speaking one more thing
i wanted to show you guys
is this on the daily time frame
we just had the macd turning positive so
once again guys
this alone is not enough to enter a
trade
but you know you can see here we we have
this kind of fake
signal given by the mcdew on the 28th of
april it was
here same thing when we broke the 100
and
173 level let me zoom in
you see here the mag returned positive
on the 28th of april it was this day
so exactly the same thing guys you know
when we confirmed here we confirmed
the breakout and still we got rejected
so once again this is not enough
like i said but it's one more
information and here
same thing is happening but this time
it's looking much better
because we have completed this complex
correction once again guys
here i struggled a bit but right now i
see it very clearly it's an abc abc
abc so it's wxy correction it's a triple
three
so it's a very common collective pattern
when you apply illiot wave theory
so this was not the case here before and
what else do we have volumes are not
with us yet all right
so we are still missing the volumes guys
but they're gonna come and you see
this is one more reason that i'm using
the log scale
because when you have the breakout you
have the volumes all right
here if you actually use the
arithmetical scale the breakout occurred
guys
but with no volume so you can see that
this is not a breakout
that the arithmetical scale doesn't make
sense
because if we have a breakout we need to
have strong volumes
and when we're gonna break out this
level
you're gonna see the volumes and this is
gonna
kind of you know prove my point i'm not
trying here to
prove my part i'm just explaining why
the logarithmic scale is the one to use
for gamestop
to me so let's see if i'm right here
what else i wanted to show you guys yes
i also had some people asking me
why 800 so let me explain again how i
find this level
so this is my whole analysis so just for
you guys
to take a step back i'm actually having
here
a one a two
a three and then maybe four and five
let's see so let me put this
purple for example all right
so for now we we are not thinking about
four and five because guys
you know if this happens this would be a
squeeze we need
to make the whole analysis again when we
have the correction after the 800 level
if we have it i'm not sure we're gonna
have it i'm just you know telling you
that usually this is what is happening
so now why 800 so to find
the highest level of my third wave i do
some fib
extension application so you measure the
first wave
and you apply to the bottom of the
second wave oh yeah sorry i put it too
high
okay so and you come up with the 110
level all right so
it's like you know an area of course
it's not very precise
i like to call it the 800 area this is
why i'm talking about this level for
such a long time
because it's the 1.618 fib extension
level so
usually when we do a third wave either
it is as long as the first wave
especially when the first wave is so
extended so this
would give me the 500 it's the one that
is here the 515 level
but guys if we go to 515 what would
happen
we know that already we know all the
cool options that we have on the 800
strike
we know that a lot of hedge funds put a
stop loss just above the maximum level
we had here at 418. so if we go to 515
it's going to blow up on the upside so
this is the reason why
i don't think the one-to-one ratio would
actually occur
between this third wave in purple and
the first wave in purple i have here i
think we're going to go to the next
field extension level which is the 1.618
which is the 800 level
so yeah i hope i managed to explain this
clearly
and one more thing guys let me show you
the financial data
so why i actually think that if we go
above 500 there's going to be a big big
move up
it's because i checked the option market
guys and i can see that on the so i have
here all my strikes
and i can see that the 800 strike has 2
million
shares on it the volatility of this
strike is 198 percent
guys so it is higher than so this is for
the july maturity games
and it is higher than it was one week
ago around
1 190 193 so this is going
higher this makes the delta of the 800
strike higher as well
and you can see here guys this is the
total synthetic short exposure right so
we have around 500 million
usd exposure on the option market short
beared by hedge funds and market makers
and it's mostly coming from the 800s
trying guys
and if gamestop goes to 500 for example
here is the synthetic shot it goes from
500 million
us dollar to 5 billion us dollars guys
do you
imagine how much this is so
this would be unbearable for a lot of
market makers and a lot of hedge funds
that would need to cut the positions
so if we go to 500 we go to 800 and if
we go to 800 the
synthetic shot is at 21
if you add to this
up right now do we have
the short interest okay we don't have
the short interest for the 30s of
april's but for the 15th of april
you know it's like 20 if you add the
synthetic shot
at the 800 strike it would be 40 so it
starts to be
hard and to be hard for those hedge
funds and market makers to hold their
short positions
so this is why 800 is my level so that's
it for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show see you guys